du kannst mir um 3 Uhr in der Früh
aufwecken und der Handgriff passt
einfach
tausende Male wiederholst
[Musik]
[Applaus]
herzlich willkommen beim sportreport dem
Sport Podcast das österreichischen
Bundesheers heute zu Gast
Oberwachtmeister Markus Weber
Vize-Weltmeister im militärischen
Fünfkampf herzlich willkommen
Kampf äh ich lass dich jetzt mal
erklären was das genau ist und aus
welchem Disziplinen er sich
zusammensetzten international an wir
haben 200 bis 300 Meter mit einem
Großkaliber Gewehr liegen frei das heißt
wir haben schießjacke an so ähnlich wie
man vielleicht das Fernsehen kennt man
nur das ist halt auf einer größeren
Distanz ist dann kommt der Hindernislauf
die militärische Hindernisbahn 500 Meter
20 Hindernisse das Höchste ist fünf
Meter die fünf Meter Leiter wobei der
dazu sagen was ist das wird die fünf
Meter Leiter springen
dann 20 Meter das längste Hindernis das
krieg ich Hindernis kostet am meisten
Energie und noch dahin kommt dann ins
Schwimmen da haben wir 50 Meter vier
Hindernisse 2 zum Überwinden 2 zum
Untertauchen dann kommt es werfen es
setzt sich zwischen Ziel werfen und weit
werfen zusammen da haben wir die Ziele
20 25 30 und 35 Meter mit immer einen
Meter Radius ist der Innenkreis und ein
Meter noch dazu ist der Außenkreis gibt
der Punktevergabe und danach kommt dabei
durch das wird dann zusammengezählt und
zum Abschluss wobei die ersten vier
Disziplinen gibt dem die Punktevergabe
und der mit dem meisten Punkte startet
dann auf die 8 km Gelände laufen und pro
Punkt ist eine Sekunde Differenz und der
als erste durchs Ziel läuft hat gewonnen
sozusagen das heißt man ähm er arbeitet
sich durch die ersten Disziplinen eine
Ausgangslage entweder einem liegt oder
in meinem nicht da liegt für den Gelände
laufen damit man dann sozusagen einen
Zieleinlauf hat ohne rechnen zu müssen
und ohne kalkulieren zu müssen sondern
wer da ist hat gewonnen genauso ist es
ja also wir starten noch gunderassen
Methode sozusagen ja das klingt so als
ob man als militärischer fünf Kämpfer
fast schon alles kennen muss also sowohl
ausdauernd sein als auch schnell sein
also zielen kann als auch weit werfen
können aber auch die Ruhe haben und der
Anspannung gut zu treffen ist es so dass
man wirklich im Endeffekt alles abdecken
muss als militärischer Fünfkämpfer ja
genau also das ist ja im Prinzip das was
in fünf Kampf ausmacht das sind halt
konzentriert sein muss wenn es darauf
ankommt aber die gewisse Power
Schnelligkeit
laktatverträglichkeit speziell auf der
Hindernisbahn und natürlich auch die
Ausdauerfähigkeit aber es ist natürlich
so man kommt jetzt wenn man zum
Fünfkampf dazu kommt nicht gleich als
perfekt das muss man sie hat dann hat er
arbeiten ja man hat gewisse Talente
natürlich aber die muss man natürlich
ausbauen und Defizite genauso ja was
sind deine Talente gewesen am Anfang
bevor du alles perfektioniert hast ja
gewesen ist Schwimmen auf jeden Fall das
dauert großes Talent gehabt bin bei 2016
bei der heimwehm habe ich schwimmen
gewonnen es hat mir sehr gefreut und
schießen es liegt mir auch wobei er dazu
sagen was sie kommt von modernen fünf
Kampf letztes Mal war der Gustav gustern
bei dir und habe da schon mit 10 Jahren
im Prinzip bin ich schon die Schiene
beim Schießen ein bisschen aber
reinschnuppern können wenn ihr da schon
relativ gut ausgebildet das waren
eigentlich die ersten Zeit Disziplinen
beim Laufen habe noch einmal
Nachholbedarf gehabt aber das hat ja
relativ gut eingependelt also auf dem
Niveau wo eigentlich hin wollte habe ich
geschafft er ist das Laufen auch die
Disziplin die man am leichtesten
sozusagen nach trainieren kann ich mir
vorstellen dass das Schwimmen oder
andere hochtechnische Disziplinen
schwieriger sind dass man sie dann
militärischen Fünfkampf ist so dass der
Ausdauer Bereich schon ein sehr
bedeutender ist und das kann man
natürlich leichter trainieren als wir
jetzt wenn man schnell kräftig ist das
ist halt schon ein bisschen Unterschied
ja aber man kann es trainieren auf jeden
Fall ja das gesagt dass das dem Modernen
Fünfkampf gegangen bist also
offensichtlich immer schon sehr
vielseitig gewesen war das ein großer
Vorteil dass das diese Vielseitigkeit
schon aus einer anderen Sport hat da war
auf jeden Fall also mein mein
Leistungssport hat eigentlich schon mit
sechs Jahren begonnen mit Dennis und bin
dann eben durch die Schule zu moderner
Fünfkampf kommen und hat mir eigentlich
immer interessiert und mein großes Ziel
war eigentlich die sie immer ins Jahre
Sportzentrum komme
und ja es war dann so genau wie der
Zeitpunkt gekommen ist das habe ich mein
Schlüsselbein brauchen und bin dann eben
dann militärischer Fünfkämpfer geworden
also es war eigentlich ein gar nicht so
beabsichtigt wobei ich würde den Schritt
genauso wenn es wieder drauf ankommt
genauso machen kann nur diesmal ohne
Schlüsselbeinbruch nur diesmal habe
einfach ja aber ich war das im Moment
als das passiert ich kann vorstellen
dass es ein großer Rückschlag ist
nicht immer gleich gewusst dass sie
dadurch so eingeschränkt gewesen bin so
da ein bisschen länger gedauert und war
dann eigentlich froh dass ich doch einen
anderen Anker hatte dass er hat mir
militärischen 5 Kampf Anfang und habe
keine Ahnung ja man Schicksal eigentlich
ja
auf jeden Fall erfolgreich ist es ja
geworden wie trainiert man so
widersprüchliche Sportarten also
Widersprüche in dem Sinne dass man
einfach komplett andere Dinge braucht
bei der Ausbau verliert man meistens
dann seine schnell Kräftigkeit wie
schafft man das
das Gute auf einen Trainingsplan zu
bringen es ist ich sage mal am Anfang
überhaupt wenn man mit dem militärischen
Fünfkampf anfangs zum Trainieren relativ
schwierig also bei mir war es halt so
dass sie meistens zum Höhepunkt
abgeschlossen gewesen bin weil er hat
durch die Umfänge des netgrund gewesen
bin hat sich dann nach der Jahre
geändert und wieder Ablauf generell so
ausschaut also wir schauen dass man halt
blockweise gewisse Sportarten trainieren
aber die Ausdauer ist halt immer dabei
also laufen ist das A und O und das
restliche wird dann halt so angepasst
vor allem dann wenn es zum Höhepunkt
kommt da werden halt wirklich schauen
diese spezifisch dieses Training dann
und das klingt ja auch
hochwissenschaftlich wie ihr trainiert
und hier vorbereitet werde der
militärische 55 natürlich
dementsprechend unterstützt und
gefördert und es ist auch wahnsinnig
viel noch da wir sind ja historisch sehr
gut
militärischen Fünfkampf profitiert man
da als Athlet von von diesem Wissen ja
auf jeden Fall also von der Trainer
angefangen bis hin natürlich auch meine
alten Kollegen wo ich sehr viel gelernt
habe ja genau dieses Wissen möchte ich
dann eigentlich auch weitergeben als
Trainer das war eben auch der Grund
warum er die ganze laufbank gemacht habe
im Bundesland also die
unteroffiziershaus Bildung weil ich das
Wissen einfach weitergeben will also bin
jetzt auch schon ein bisschen so einer
Trainertätigkeit mit eingebunden und ja
voraussichtlich dann nächstes Jahr meine
letzte Saison also ich wollte eigentlich
seit 2019 immer noch ein großes eigenes
machen das nicht so funktioniert weil
immer abgesagt worden ist und deswegen
ist halt nächstes Jahr so mein großes
Ziel noch mal eine Medaille zu machen
und dann in den Trainer starb sozusagen
überzugehen und dann das Wissen
weitergeben das soll natürlich auf der
nächsten Generation förderlich sein wie
die Tasche 5 kämpfen wird besonders
gefährdet das ist eine Schwerpunkt
Sportart im österreichischen Bundesheer
ist in dem Sinne was anderes als eben
olympische oder paralympische Sportdaten
weil sie einen militärischen Sinn und
Zweck auch hat warum wird dieser Sport
dazu besonders gefährdet wir es gibt den
internationalen seasonverband das ist
sozusagen der militärische
internationale Sportverband und da
werden eben diese große Ereignisse
veranstaltet wo hat also total das Motor
lautet friendship supports wo alle
Sportsoldaten sozusagen hinkommen
Freundschaften schließen das ist eben
auch im Prinzip die Förderung warum ist
militäre so machen ja
es gibt aber natürlich auch Synergien
die man nutzen kann in der in der
militärischen Ausbildung gibt es Dinge
die du besonders gut kannst die jeder
Soldat in österreichischen Bundesheer
keine sollte man von dir sozusagen
lernen kann dass das deiner sportlichen
Tätigkeit ja also wir sind natürlich
auch eingebunden zum Beispiel
grundverdiener auszubilden also da haben
wir immer wieder dass man mit den Grund
verdienen auch die Hindernisbahn gehen
das hat doch glaube ich für jeden tolles
Ereignis ist aber die Hindernisbahn zu
bewältigen was doch sehr fordernd ist
und das immer eingebunden und ich bin da
mit der Schule mit der BHAG mit der
sicherheitsschule in Wiener Neustadt da
haben wir einmal Training und das talkt
in den Kids und so kann ja das Wissen
ein bisschen weitergeben auch breiter
jetzt nicht nur im in der eigenen
Mannschaft sondern auch ein bisschen
breiter
einer großen Erfolge weiter
Weltmeistertitel bei der
Weltmeisterschaft 2018
ein sehr gute Frage weil man ist so
einen Tunnel das ist eigentlich
automatisch Ablauf ist natürlich der
Druck kommt dazu das ist klar aber mit
dem lernt man also für mich ist es so
das lernt man einfach mit den Jahren und
irgendwie pusht es sogar muss ich sagen
also so herausfordernd ja ich sage mal
der Druck natürlich auch bei der
heimweltmeisterschaft ist höher als
woanders ganz klar aber irgendwie
beflügelte sondern aber wir schaffen das
das auszublenden ich meine in den Tunnel
zu kommen in den Flo zu kommen aber da
muss man wahrscheinlich auch bewusst
ausblenden dass jetzt z.B das ist kein
Publikum da ist dass die
Erwartungshaltung in einem positiven
Stress und wandeln das ist vielleicht so
mein mein Zugang also genau das Negative
ins Positive wechseln das heißt da auf
auf das Positive fokussieren und die
Energie nutzen die freigesetzt wird ich
erinnere mich dass ich zum ersten mal
ein Video gesehen habe von militärischen
5 kämpfen das war glaube ich der
Weltmeistertitel von Österreich vor
einigen Jahren jetzt schon im Finale
gegen China wo ein sehr sehr spannender
ist Parcours bewältigt wurde und da sich
die ähm teilweise Kopf voraus
fünf Meter Hindernis runter werfen mich
nach der poch das ist das ist nicht ohne
ja spielt auch ein bisschen Angst mit
bei solchen Hindernissen Angst nicht
wenn man es im Training sowieso oft nur
durchmacht der Respekt ist auf jeden
Fall da weil du warst dort bei jedem
Hindernis kann irgendwas passieren aber
wenn das nur so unspektakulär ausschaut
man braucht nur irgendwo ein für fadeln
oder hängen bleiben also ich habe schon
so ziemlich alles gesehen auf der
Hindernisbahn was gibt der also wirklich
nicht ohne also kann jedem empfehlen da
mal auf Youtube zuschauen und
militärischer Fünfkampf einzugeben es
hat aber so gewirkt als wäre wirklich
jeder Handgriff optimiert also jeder
jeder Griff jeder Sprung jeder Schritt
war fast schon automatisiert macht man
das bewusst so
ob es bewusst ist oder unbewusste kann
das eigentlich gar nicht sagen also ich
würde schon unbewusst eher sagen ja was
ist wie gesagt im Training heute auch
über den Wettkampf Tempo oft genug
gemacht und das schleift sie das hat
nach einer Zeit an das ist halt wirklich
ja du kannst mir um 300 früher aufwecken
und der Handgriff passt einfach es ist
halt wirklich tausende Male wiederholst
und das braucht es wahrscheinlich auch
weil der die Zeit beim Hindernisse nicht
lang oder geht sie wirklich dann um
Zehntel und Hundertstel und da hat man
vielleicht ein wenig Zeit zu überlegen
na wie gehe ich jetzt hier das Hindernis
an oder es muss einfach zum Zeit zum
Überlegen eigentlich gar nicht mehr
jeden Lauf natürlich geht das Ganze im
Kopf durch das mache ich schon und da
war sie halt da die die Schritte das hat
sie halt einfach über die Jahre
eingespielt aber das jetzt kurzzeitig
vor dem Hindernis überlegen okay muss
jetzt mit dem linken Fuß weg hüpfen oder
mit Rechten da ist es dann eher
schwieriger und vor allem dann zum
Schluss wenn das Laktat dann Einfahrt
sozusagen da gibt es dann sowieso nichts
mehr zum Überlegen wird da muss das
automatisiert sein das Ganze vor allem
es ist zum Schluss an der
balancierhindernis da muss halt wirklich
jeder Handgriff eigentlich passen das
ist wahrscheinlich auch ganz bewusste
dort hingestellt
hat noch die Herausforderung hat beim
Schwimmen ist ja auch so also ich sehe
euch ja immer wieder in der Südstadt
wenn ihr kommt und Hindernisse aufbaut
wahrscheinlich immer fasziniert dazu da
müsste ja auch im Endeffekt ganz genau
wissen zwei Züge schwimmen dann geht's
aufs Hindernis dann abstoßen das muss ja
auch komplett durch optimiert sein oder
ja genau also wir schauen natürlich auch
im Training dass wir ähm also sozusagen
gemacht und dass man halt wirklich so
schnell so schnell kräftig weil im
Training kriegst du heute diese Spannung
aus dem Bett kommt fast nie hin
doch dann hat kürzere Abschnitte und da
schauen wir halt wirklich so schnell wie
möglich über die Hindernisse zu gehen
und das ganze optimiert hat mit Züge mit
gleiten also ja der Startsprung
natürlich ganz wichtig das wirst du
erkennen vom Schwimmen und ja da tun wir
immer verfeinern wieder Analyse gibt es
alles drum und dran ja was für
Rahmenbedingungen braucht man dafür ich
nehme an
dass man das nicht unbedingt in jedem
Schwimmbecken aufbauen kann oder also im
Prinzip könntest du sogar in jedem Film
Becken aufbauen weil es ist der Tisch
das ist eigentlich das größte Hindernis
der ist meistens schwimmend und ihr seid
zum regelmaß aufgenommen worden ist ja
nicht mehr steht eben wegen dem Becken
Tiefe dass man da halt wirklich
verschwimmen das hat und es gibt da 25
mcken das das Schlimmste heute dann ist
die Wände entweder beim Tisch oder
fantastisch die Wände also es gibt alle
Variationen wobei dazu sagen was bei der
WM ist standardisiert immer 50 Meter
gewesen das heißt wenn man für die
Weltmeisterschaft trainiert dann weiß
man genau so wird es auch beim Wettkampf
sein und kann die Abstände zwischen die
Hindernis ist immer gleich das Wasser
natürlich das ist da erkennen das ist
immer ein bisschen anders aber das ist
ja gefühlsache aber die Hindernisse
selber sondern eigentlich genormt und
immer gleich ja aber jetzt wenn du das
Gefühl anspricht so dass wir eben vom
Wasser Gefühl reden was natürlich keiner
versteht
oder besser zum Greifen
durch also aber natürlich wenn man
mehrere Stunden am Tag in dem Element
sich aufhält spürt man sofort jeder
Veränderung könnt ihr dieses Gefühl auch
aufbauen wenn ihr fünf Sportarten
funktioniert weil ihr seid ja nicht
tagtäglich im Wasser sondern müsste sich
das ja gut einteilen in der Woche kann
man da überhaupt ein Gefühl für jede
dieser Stadt hatten entwickeln also wie
nur mehr geschwommen bin weiß Gefühl
schon anders muss ich dazu sagen aber es
hat ja adoptiert so immer über die Zeit
es ist so
viel früher hat für die 200 Meter
trainiert habe war wenn ich zwar Tag
nicht schwimmen war aber dieser
Katastrophen es ist sozialgefühlt wie
wenn ich am Mensch bin und überhaupt
nicht schwimmen kann das hat sie jetzt
durch das wir heute nicht jeden Tag
schwimmen sondern vielleicht zwei bis
dreimal in der Woche hat sie das Gefühl
ein bisschen verändert ja und bei den
anderen Disziplinen ist das dort kann
man das auch rekonstruieren oder ist
einfach weil es kein fremdes Element ist
dann anders doch doch also du hast jetzt
wenn er beim Schießen anfangen hast du
schon
sozusagen so Höhepunkte also wo der hat
wirklich super fühlst also bei der
Aufbau Phase wenn man sie ist das erste
Mal noch im Winter wieder mal rein legt
man reinlegen schaffen Schuss tätig weil
wir machen Anschlag Übungen im Winter
auch hat drinnen
und sobald es dann zum scharfen Schuss
kommt und dann wieder draußen liegen es
ist schon wieder Umstellung aber das
wird dann eben wenn es dann zum
Höhepunkt kommt dass sie immer besser in
Form kommen sozusagen also es merkt man
schon ja es fühlt sich einfach besser an
und es zieht sie eigentlich bei der
anderen Disziplinen Hindernisbahn
genauso durch und da beim Laufen oder
Schwimmen immer wie sehr kann man das
Ziel und weit werfen mit Wurf
Disziplinen in der Leichtathletik
vergleichen kann man da von dem
Speerwerfer was lernen oder ja also der
Weitwurf definitiv das Problem ist dass
wir nur drei Meter zum angegeben haben
und danach ist die Mauer die hat relativ
gut blockiert was du heute nicht drüber
gehen kannst oder nicht so gut es ist
schwer Wurf ähnlich sage immer der
Weitwurf
Zielwurf
gibt es eigentlich nicht wirklich was
vergleichbares es ist halt die Männer um
550 Gramm also die Eisenkugel sozusagen
oder die Granate die muss militärisch
sagt
ist halt der Zielwurf schon komplett was
anderes ja kann man dann zum Beispiel
beim Laufen mit
Cross Country Läufern trainieren damit
man da die acht Kilometer Gelände gut
hinbekommt oder beim Werfen mit einem
Speerwerfer oder beim Schießen mit den
Sport schützen kann man da auch mit
ihnen trainieren und da sich was
abschauen ja also es war jetzt zum
Beispiel verarbeiten schon zusammen im
letztes Jahr haben mein Lienz Land
Trainingskurs gemacht mit die Schützen
und da lernt man halt so relativ viel
Weisheit als mehr Kämpfer sozusagen hast
du heute nie Zeit das tolle 50
Disziplinen so durch
trainierst oder durch denkst oder
irgendwelche z.B beim Gewehr des Motor
ein bisschen was verfeinert die Schützen
beschäftigen sie hat jeden Tag
eigentlich damit und da kannst du sehr
viel lernen das ist halt sozusagen dass
man die Zeit von den Schützen ein
bisschen dass man da Erfahrung sammelt
und wissen
machen genau
natürlich geteilt werden kann jetzt hast
du vorher schon angesprochen du wolltest
immer Leistungssportler werden weil das
immer zum herdersport das ist über
militärischen Fünfkampf gelungen aber
das auch angesprochen dass du dann
weiter Ausbildungen gemacht hast was die
Optionen hättest du denn gehabt als
herdersportler der dann sagt ich würde
gerne beim Bundesheer bleiben ich mag
nicht dass wenn meine militärische 5
Karriere zu Ende geht ich ähm
abschlusste was hättest du alles machen
können
also du meinst es Leistungssportler wenn
jetzt nicht die militärische Laufbahn
oder schon auch die militärische
Laufbahn was für Optionen gibt es da als
Leistungssportler also es ist so das
sowieso Nachwuchsbedarf ist generell im
herbstzentrum also da wird werden immer
wird die Personal gesucht und daher und
für mich eigentlich recht gut ergeben
dass sie heute dann wirklich in die
Trainer Tätigkeiten dann reinkomme das
war eigentlich der Grund warum ich dafür
entschieden habe das auch gesagt dass du
die unteroffizierst als Bildung gemacht
hast was war alles Teil dieser
Ausbildung also das ganze dauert
eineinhalb Jahre
für mich war immer die dekadenwerte
Ausbildung eins wo ein weiterer da macht
halt Jäger Teile das heißt schießen dann
enttäuschen Gefechtsausbildung
Orient Geländer also die die komplette
Basis was er da jeder Soldat benötigt
danach habe ich die Cap zwei Ausbildung
gemacht die war in Wien auf der hallo
guess das hat mit Versorgung zu tun
gehabt und danach bist du eine halbe
halbes Jahr auf der
heraus unter 40 Akademie und da wird
dann eben von politische Bildung bis
Ausbildung und so weiter also wie immer
grundverdiener ausbildet sozusagen
Gelehrter das heißt deswegen auch der
Schritt ins weitergeben deines Wissens
natürlich liegt jetzt auf der Hand aber
du hast natürlich auch von deinen
sportlichen Fähigkeiten in der
Ausbildung profitiert man weiß ja dass
diese Ausbildung intensiv sind ist das
von Vorteil wenn man da als
Leistungssportler hinkommt naja
natürlich also die körperlichen Vorteile
die die Haustür natürlich aus
Leistungssportler aber natürlich der
Schlafanzug ist was anderes also da habe
ich am Anfang ein Probleme Probleme es
war halt für mich ein bisschen fordern
das sage mal so weißt du das
leistungssportel doch gewöhnt bist noch
ein Training ruhen das hat dort nicht
gehen da geht's hat Vollgas weiter und
ich habe seit von meiner anderen
Kameraden schon gesehen dass die mehr
gelitten haben als wie ich also
körperlich natürlich schon einen riesen
Vorteil ja das ist natürlich dann auch
in deiner weiteren Tätigkeit zeigen zum
Abschluss Liebe Markus habe ich noch ein
paar kurze Fragen an dich was wolltest
du denn als Kind werden ich habe aber
boah Sachen gehabt also ich wollte
Zirkus Akrobat werden was eigentlich zu
Hindernis passt
dann wollte ich Bauer werden aber die
Landwirtschaft gemacht
und ja Sportler war natürlich also
Leistungssportler na mein Ziel ein einen
Traum hast du dir in diesem Jahr wieder
füllt den anderen dazu Hälfte weil
natürlich viele Fertigkeiten die auch
noch als Circus Akrobatik braucht der
wichtig sind das wärst du ohne Sport ich
bin sehr unausgeglichen also ich brauche
halt meine tägliche Dosis sage ich mal
weil sonst bin ich unterstelle
was ist denn deine stärkste Eigenschaft
dass sie verlässlich bin also bin einer
denke ich und ich habe davon ein paar
Seiten gehört dass sie sehr verlässlich
bin das ist mein Bundeswehr sehr gut
alle freuen mit denen du noch zu tun
haben wirst was ist denn dein unnützes
ist Talent
ist vielleicht ein bisschen bin
und Talent war sie wieder jetzt nicht
sagen
und wovon treibst du was ist ein großer
Traum was möchtest du nach schaffen also
was ich noch erreichen will ist mit
Teile im Einzel bei der
Weltmeisterschaft das ist mein großes
Ziel das hast du schon angekündigt
nächstes Jahr zum großen Abschluss eine
einzelne Medaille wir wünschen dir eine
gute Vorbereitung vielen Dank
hoffentlich findet die WM auch statt wir
gehen davon aus und wird natürlich auch
für nachher noch alles Gute danke schön
danke Markus Weber das war's von uns
beim Wort herzlichen Dank fürs dabei
sein bis zum nächsten Mal
[Musik]
[Applaus]